en algunos momentos de nuestra vida nos
preguntamos sobre todo si son críticos o
de felicidad que me dará la vida que
tendré de la vida que obtendré de la
vida
a lo largo de mi carrera hotelera y
dentro de la industria turística
siempre con equipo he podido generar
riqueza beneficios prosperidad y muchos
puestos de trabajo
inicialmente
esos beneficios y esas rentabilidades
iban enfocadas
a retornos de invención
retornos de beneficios altos que
prácticamente no tenían impacto en la
sociedad en la que estábamos
siempre hemos pensado que quisiéramos
para nuestras familias y para nosotros
mismos
cierta comunidad económica ciertos
bienes materiales que puedan garantizar
nos una muy buena subsistencia
de esa manera inicia mi vida
quería para mi hija jessica y mi mujer
andrea lo mejor en términos económicos
que nunca le faltase de nada que tuviese
en esa comodidad de que todo lo podrían
tener
pero me di cuenta de que no era así que
si yo bien caminaba por una senda de
comodidad económica mi mujer lo hacía
por otra senda diferente que era de
ayuda a la sociedad y a las personas que
estaban
el cautivo y dio un giro un giro que fue
importante en mi vida y que era el deseo
que yo quería para mi hija de manera que
ella viera en el reflejo mío y en el de
su madre que en esta vida hay que ser
condescendientes y que hay que ayudar al
prójimo giro importante que he intentado
extrapolar en 17 ciudades
12 países y cuatro continentes
todo inició en el sureste asiático en
tailandia el hotel donde trabajaba se
encontraba ubicado en un lugar
paradisíaco era un gran hotel de lujo de
cinco estrellas uno de los que más
destacaba y se veían a leguas los
contrastes contrastes entre aquellos que
podían recibir
y aquellos otros que podían dar y mucho
y no lo hacían
mi mujer decidió apoyar a un pequeño
orfanato iniciamos con una niña
y terminamos con 10 niños de ese módulo
de 4 unidades
la compañía me anuncia un cambio de
destino
un cambio de país y así me generan
estrés de bancos de teléfonos de pensar
dónde vamos la incertidumbre de qué va a
pasar con nosotros a quién conoceremos y
la tristeza de lo que está en una parte
pero luego yo pensaba y qué les pasará
esos niños quien continuará con su
educación quién les va a apoyar que
podemos darles a esos niños nos vamos y
ya está
convencí motive al compañero que me iba
a sustituir como director del hotel y él
continuó con el proyecto es más como
todo el orfanato y le dio sostenimiento
durante muchos años
maletas en mano y nos trasladamos a bali
indonesia la isla de los dioses allí
llegamos con la intención de aportar y
dar algo pero no lo sabíamos qué hacer
por tanto preguntamos al equipo si
alguien sabía que se podría hacer por la
comunidad apenas hablábamos el idioma
pero sabíamos que lo queríamos aprender
y nos dijeron si existe una escuela de
sordomudos de niños sordomudos que
posiblemente precise de su ayuda en este
caso y va a ser una ayuda individual
durante muchas semanas intentamos con
dos niños hacer que su vida sea mucho
mejor de lo que así tenía
continuamos trabajando con ellos
haciendo manualidades aprendiendo de
ellos el lenguaje de signos y a su vez
ellos aprendiendo de nosotros algunas
expresiones y comodidades que les
pudiésemos dar
en un momento se me ocurre mencionarlo
en algo que llamamos el morning briefing
en los hoteles la reunión de la mañana y
dije hoy por la tarde así que iré a esa
escuela de sordomudos cualquiera que
quiera venir conmigo es bienvenido
les conté un poquito que estábamos
haciendo y mi sorpresa fue grande cuando
fuimos al parque en mi mujer y yo le
dije bueno pienso que a lo mejor dos
vendrán con nosotros
llego al parking y me sorprendo diez
personas diez compañeros que quieren
unirse a ese proyecto
luego fueron 20 luego 40 hasta que
decidí hacer algo ya lo tenía bastante
organizado ya estaba estructurado ya
sabíamos que estábamos haciendo por los
chicos
era tiempo de que participaran los
clientes pero qué clientes y dije
primero aquellos clientes regulares que
vienen con frecuencia y que sabemos que
podrían hacer un efecto multiplicador y
así fue yo lo dije a clientes alemanes
australianos austriacos y españoles
ellos entre ellos hicieron luego una
labor de replicar lo que estábamos
haciendo y dentro de sus vacaciones
dedicaban uno o dos días en un cierto
tiempo a acompañar y ayudar a los niños
sordomudos a darle espacios no sólo
bienes materiales a acompañar de ellos
que fueran unas mejores personas
reconstruimos la escuela ayudamos en la
cocina hicimos sus dormitorios hicimos
sus aulas les proveemos con materiales
técnicos también para que pudieran saber
y aprendimos de ellos muchas cosas
20 años después ese legado continúa y
seguimos estando con ellos pero había
una cosa que pasaba con los chicos
cuando cumplían 18 años y estaba notando
que eran invitados a no continuar a la
escuela y salir e buscarse una vida como
la buscamos nosotros a los 18 años
enfrentarse con todo lo que hay pero con
ciertas deficiencias en unos lugares que
bastante difícil lo tienen por tanto
propuse el director del colegio de la
escuela me permite que los chicos cuando
terminen y cumplan sus 18 años puedan
integrarse con nosotros en el hotel a
trabajar se quedó sorprendido y en que
van a ayudar
pues terminaron trabajando en áreas
públicas en lavandería en jardinería en
mantenimiento en administración porque
eran muy capaces y eso sigue siendo
cuando terminan su colegio aquellos que
lo deseen
después de los 18 años tienen una
oportunidad en ese lugar en bali donde
están
maleta en mano y pi pi pi suena el
cambio cambio de país cambio de lugar
cambio de maletas a ver cuánto nos llega
del equipaje que tenemos a buscar de
nuevo colegio a abrir facturas bancarias
etcétera etcétera y nos trasladamos a
yakarta la capital de indonesia una mega
urbe cerca de 30 millones de habitantes
con unas inclemencias de tiempo bastante
relevantes cada vez que llovía allí se
notaba y se notaba de manera visual se
desbordaban las las avenidas y las
aceras eran prácticamente invisibles
yendo en un buen coche a una visita
comercial me di cuenta de que si ya era
difícil moverse en circunstancias
normales cuando apenas se ven las aceras
como lo podría estar haciendo una
persona que difícilmente caminaba y
tenía dificultades motrices y ese fue el
enfoque nos enfocamos a aquellas
personas con discapacidades motrices
empezamos con sillas de ruedas y un
premio de 25 mil euros que me dieron de
solidaridad lo dediqué íntegramente a un
centro de rehabilitación motriz allí
pudieron ayudar con el tema de prótesis
repararlas poder tener un ortopeda poder
dar clases a aquellas personas de
rehabilitación poder tener una sala de
orientación y recibir a aquellas
personas que habían tenido accidentes o
amputaciones y que tendrían que formar
parte de ese nuevo proceso de vida
fuimos el primer hotel
en el sureste asiático y lo recuerdo
porque salía en los periódicos
que integró dentro de su plantilla
laboral a una persona invidente a una
chica que trabaja en el departamento de
teléfono y que sigue estando allí vi la
oportunidad de hacerlo de forma
organizada y estructurada con unicef de
manera que la educación de los niños y
el cuidado infantil pudiese estar
regulado de una manera uniforme cambió
maletas y a otro continente y ese otro
continente de esa américa y esas
ciudades la ciudad de mexico el hotel
también muy bien emplazado estábamos en
uno de los mejores barrios del distrito
federal donde bajarse y que lo he hecho
veía veía prosperidad veía beneficios
veía grandes restaurantes veía gente muy
bien vestida apenas se veía necesidad
pregunté al equipo si alguien sabía qué
podíamos hacer para aportar valor y en
este caso eran valor inicial del momento
mi mujer y yo y también se uniría a mi
hija y me dijeron
hay una oportunidad y hay un pequeño
hospicio en ese oficio están niños con
el virus decida yo ya qué distancia está
a un kilómetro y medio perfecto antes de
tomar un coche caminando iremos más
rápido nos acercamos nos acercamos a los
pisos y estaban ahí los niños tenían
facilidades correctas si se notaba que
estaban bien cuidados en ese momento no
había el conocimiento que hoy se tiene
de ser un portador o no portador del vih
pero allí veías que los niños contentos
del todo no estaban no los sacaban no
los llevaban a jugar estaban
prácticamente recluidos muchos de ellos
claro te miraban que decían ti que viene
a ser este señor todo lo contrario
había había mucho mucho que hacer por
los niños volví muy pensativo y bastante
pensativo y dije aquí hay que hacer algo
diferente no podemos ir haciendo siempre
lo mismo y está a un kilómetro y medio
de donde está el hotel por tanto propuse
al equipo del hotel que ha sido lo sé lo
deseas
manera desinteresada que hagamos una
adopción
virtual una adopción de esos niños en
las cuales se van a integrar
los hijos de mis colaboradores y los q
niego es cónyuges o parejas del
colaborador no iba a ser sólo el
colaborador y vamos todos en familia y
esa adopción simbólica se iba a hacer
por tanto así fue pedimos autorización
al director de esos vicios nos dijo que
nadie se había planteado todo ello se
nos fue asignando a cada uno de los
chicos y vamos a tener nosotros la
responsabilidad de acompañar seríamos
más o menos su segunda familia por una
segunda familia integrada con el
colaborador y los hijos de ese
colaborador lo llevamos al hotel donde
trabajamos compartimos con las
instalaciones del hotel lo llevamos al
cine a parques de atracciones etcétera
etcétera y se creó un vínculo muy bonito
sobre todo teniendo en cuenta que los
hijos de nuestros colaboradores ya
empezaban a ver la importancia que eran
el respeto a la comunidad
tín tín tín tín y otra vez otro cambio
más agarra maletas cambiado de bancos
cambios de destino cambio de lugar y a
ver cuántas cosas no lleguen
prácticamente nos estábamos haciendo a
un solo lugar ya empezamos a conocer la
ciudad
y en menos de nueve meses cambio y
cambios a playa del carmen quintana roo
en méxico el sur un gran destino una
ciudad nueva una ciudad vibrante con
cierto poderío económico y con una gran
oferta de empleo muchísimos hoteles por
construir me pregunte y qué vamos a
hacer aquí pero si teníamos algo muy
claro que mucho ya podíamos implementar
de lo que se estaba haciendo en el
pasado a veces pensamos que la
oportunidad de dar está justo al lado de
nosotros no hay que buscarla más lejos
de lo que hay y que hicimos nosotros
pues bueno me di cuenta y de manera muy
rápida
que en hoteles nuevos donde podemos
llegar a tener 1500 a 2000 personas
aplicando para poder trabajar allí
muchos de los que estaban rellenando ese
formulario
venían del sector primario venían de la
agricultura de la ganadería o de la
construcción notaba que algunos de ellos
no sabían o muchos de ellos escribir o
leer correctamente
por tanto ese fue el primer inicio a los
pocos meses la educación enfoque a la
educación hicimos convenios con escuelas
primarias y secundarias y sobre todo
contratamos a personal profesores
cualificados para que los tres últimos
años de la preparatoria nuestros
colaboradores lo estudiasen desde el
propio hotel no tenían que irse a ningún
sitio ahí tenían las aulas y podría ser
dentro de las horas lectivas de trabajo
en el hotel
y luego contratamos e hicimos convenios
con universidades dos de ellas y dos de
ellas técnicas de manera que los
estudiantes que estaban en esas
universidades pusieran pudieran hacer
las prácticas técnicas bien sea de
alimentos y bebidas de administración de
mantenimiento o arias varias dentro de
los establecimientos de los hoteles
nuestros y de igual manera nuestros
colaboradores que ya estaban terminando
la preparatoria pudieran irse
directamente a esas universidades y de
igual manera creamos un anteproyecto con
eso concluía mi estancia en playa del
carmen quería hacer algo grande quería
hacer algo donde se pudiera decir que se
pueda dejar una huella pero sabía que no
lo podía hacer solo por tanto preparamos
un esquema de trabajo y proyecto entre
los hoteles y muchos de los hoteles y el
ayuntamiento de manera que los mega
hoteles que estaban allí de más de 500
600 700 900 habitaciones pudiesen tener
una guardería dentro del hotel cedida
por el hotel
mantenida por el hotel y el ayuntamiento
pudiese encargarse vía enfermería o
educadores o montero monitores de los
niños de nuestros colaboradores que
están desempeñando sus funciones en el
hotel un gran proyecto que todavía se
está trabajando y que nosotros quisimos
dejar como semillas para que se pueda
desarrollar
república dominicana maleta equipaje
mudanzas barcos etcétera etcétera rogar
que todo llega en tiempo que no haya
problemas en aduanas sentimientos
encontrados lloro tristeza por dejar lo
que tenemos pero alegría por saber lo
que podemos tener varios proyectos
iniciamos el primero de ellos era
capacitación promover esa capacitación
entre todos nosotros luego nos dimos
cuenta de que podíamos hacer temas de
equidad equidad de género no todos
necesariamente tienen que ser hombres en
el hotel porque no balancearlo y me
propuse tener chicas en el departamento
de mantenimiento pintoras en el
departamento de mantenimiento y resulta
que son las que mejores pintas con más
cuidado y con más detalle me propuse
también ver y observar cómo y cuánto
tiempo le toman a nuestros colaboradores
desplazarse hasta sus casas que
normalmente viven fuera de punta cana
volver a venir pierden casi un día de
ida otro día de vuelta y reparar en la
consideración de horarios ver que si van
a salir vayan y vean a su familia como
toque y que si hay días perdidos en el
desplazamiento pero contemplemos para
que puedan disfrutar de ello nos dimos
cuenta también de que habían muchas
personas que por alguna u otra manera
solicitaban puestos de trabajo con
nosotros y se notaba que estaban en
vulnerabilidad bien sea violencia o no
de género o bien sea porque la necesidad
apremiaba y eran madres la mayoría de
ellas mujeres con niños de diferentes
uniones y le dije al equipo cuando vean
esto y tengamos disponibilidad de plaza
vamos a contratarles
no hay que hacerle más análisis ni
exámenes ni test entran a trabajar con
nosotros porque ellas son las primeras y
más comprometidas con todo y así fue y
así están y vienen y trabajan hasta las
horas que haga falta
vimos también en él
de desarrollo sostenible había muchísimo
por hacer una gran cantidad de cosas lo
fuimos haciendo de manera gradual
también nos seguimos cuenta de la
importancia que tenía
el ser y el fomentar
internamente dentro de nuestros
colaboradores algo que nos va a impactar
a todos nosotros cada vez más y cada vez
más que es la economía circular para mí
creo que es una de las maneras como
poder devolver a la sociedad sobre todo
aquellos que son miembros de la sociedad
y tienen ciertas dificultades para poder
salir adelante
cuando yo estaba haciendo todos estos
trabajos y siempre lo digo con equipo
quería hacer eso que los demás lo
supieran y siempre que me invitaban a
poder extrapolar aquellas cosas que
estábamos haciendo haciendo mi ánimo era
contagiar a ustedes contagiar a las
personas que están aquí y que piensen
que ese poder de dar está en nosotros
que esa semilla de dar la tenemos
nosotros mismos aquí y empezamos
normalmente con nuestras familias con
nuestros hijos que vean que somos
solidarios con todo lo que recibimos de
la comunidad y luego replicar y
multiplicar todas las políticas de
responsabilidad social corporativa que
nuestras diferentes empresas tenemos que
la escuchamos que la vemos pero a veces
no las replicamos y por último auto
motivarnos convencer y motivar al resto
de personas que hay mucho por poder
hacer y que para hacer eso solamente se
necesita la predisposición pero si
hacerlo de una manera honesta sincera
desinteresada y sobre todo
hacerlo de corazón siempre de una manera
humana y que esto sea el reflejo de
todos nosotros muchas gracias